each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thank you so much this is the software
and services section and as in other
sections where you have a 20-minute
speaker format with 10 minutes question
thereafter and I'm going to ask you to
the speakers to actually stay on time
and apologies in advance i will be a
little bit ruthless about time i have a
little saying that I say to my wife even
though you have checks in your checkbook
and no money doesn't mean you can
continue to write checks if you're a
speaker and you have slides in your
PowerPoint and you have no more time it
doesn't mean that you could use the
powerpoint so our first speaker are the
morning Steven Johnson thank you very
much tom good morning everyone I'm
Steven Johnston from the University of
Southampton my presentation today is
about software plus services for
engineers we are a Microsoft Institute
for high performance computing and I
work for the center of food mechanical
simulation mechanic simulations to give
you an overview of what I'm going to
cover today and can give you a brief
introduction describe what i'm talking
about when I'm saying software plus
services I'm going to talk about three
proof of concepts which you've done at
university of southampton over the last
three years with with industry and then
it'll be a few minutes at the end for
some questions and answers so the main
objective is to look at the enterprise
engineering process if we can understand
how the how the enterprise is
engineering and processing things we can
gain a better ball once we have a better
understanding we can improve and
optimize the process so what do I mean
by this for example Airbus is looking at
having the time it takes to bring an
airplane from from an idea to production
and to do this they need to optimize the
engineering processes that go on behind
this one of the key things that's coming
out from this is that you need to
separate the infrastructure issues
the engineers the engineers need to have
the ability to carry on doing
engineering and not have to be concerned
with computer science issues what's the
size of my cluster where does my day to
live these are not issues and interview
should have to deal with so the idea is
to take a look at the technology excuse
me the technology that's available today
and the future technology that's coming
up and to see how we can use this to
assist engineers in the tasks that
they're doing now i mentioned we're
going to talk about three proof of
concepts to give you a rough idea of
what i'm talking about with a proof of
concept these are little projects that
we run we go out into industry we do an
ad s and architectural design session
that last one to two days where we go
out and we look at a general problem we
take a specific case of that problem and
we're looking to see what technologies
can be applied to it at the end of those
one or two days we have an architectural
concept of what we would like to what
what technology we'd like to use to
solve the problem and then usually
there's a one or two week last period
where we organize their staff and
hardware and so forth and the actual
development takes place over two to
three weeks the projects are very short
and the idea is at the end of the two
two or three weeks there's a
demonstration which shows a working
prototype the proof of concept and how
it can be applied to the specific case
also showing how it can scale to the
general case and and we go through a
user case sample an example so that
gives you an idea that these are very
short projects and the idea is to bring
out and enhance and show what features
in the technology can be applied and to
show how they actually do work in
reality software plus services what our
software plus services so and often
you'll hear people to hide okay do any
effect I'm doing your thin client shoot
my application run locally is it mobile
should it run on the cloud now these are
often more questions and software bus
service just replace or with and it's a
hybrid it's basically taking its
wrapping up a hybrid so a fat client
with services it's nothing new it's just
a new phrase and it's a you've got
you've got a allocate
some words too and these are the words
that have been chosen so this this
includes things like rest WCF service
orientated architecture software as a
service and the web two point not
technologies so for example Google
Documents is software as a service your
have a thin client and you're receiving
an application which you have features
and that is software as a service
whereas like office if we take word as
an example word is quite a fat client
but it is enhanced by features which
which you receive through other services
for example you can do search for
clipart you can do search for clipart
online you're using the service you're
consuming any service online cloud
computing if you want to call it that
you can do online help you can do the
update so an update is a form of service
so the idea of a software for service is
basically and collect all of these
technologies together and and using them
so on to the first proof of concept
first proof of concept was done with
rolls-royce the general idea behind this
is to look at the design and
optimization process now when I'm
talking about design and optimization
process the example we were using as a
turbine blade and generally you have an
optimizer and after you after you
optimize our it's going to put some
parameters and it the entire mesh the
mesh you're going to run through some
CFD and the results from your CFD
computational fluid dynamics these
results from your CFD are going to go
back into the optimizer and the
optimizer is going to calculate what to
do for the next step it's a very general
problem and sorry can everyone hear okay
maybe I should pelea or the micron so
I'm sorry and so the idea is that this
this is a very common loop so you have
you have your optimizer that's then do
some processing and you're going back to
your optimizer again and the idea is
that as you can see this is a sort of a
workflow issue and we we are actually
using widows workflow foundation to
solve this problem currently it's done
using scripts and so what we're doing
with windows workflow is we're taking
each
of the applications are in here and
turning them into an activity in the
workflow and we're using workflow to
orchestrate and manage all of the
execution so the advantages of this are
that i'll show you an architectural
diagram here you go so what we're using
on the so on your right hand side you
have the computational resources so
workflow is doing the orchestration it's
saying what processes should be run
which are now wrapped up as activities
these activities are dot net objects
which really extensible so you can
inherit from them and extend them so
we're extending them so that an activity
now has the ability to execute on and
we've provided CCS or at the time what
was called as compute cluster services
it's now windows hpc server so that is
executing on a windows cluster you can
execute on a local machine and we also
have the ability to execute on a Linux
cluster in this example actually for a
rolls-royce all of the processes are
actually running on Linux machines
except for the cfd which we're running
on Windows hvc and the optimizer which
we're running on the local machine as a
demonstration of how the workflow can be
used orchestrate across the three
different three different scenarios so
the workflow runtime actually offers us
inbuilt tracking so every activity we
can record which what properties are
going in and out of the activity and
we're were offer offered persistence so
a workflow can be saved you can restart
your machine and you can bring it back
up again and the idea is that this this
infrastructure is providing you a lot of
the features that that you need as an
engineer so the the client side of this
we're looking you you can edit workflow
in visual studio or we have a custom
interface the custom interface and all
the visualizers for workflow are Rijo
stable so you can host them in your own
forums and for reporting we're using the
tracking database the tracking database
our labels you because you're tracking
the information is going in and out of
each activity you're getting
effectively for free and it's extensible
you can add your own tracking
information the idea is that you could
build your own reports if you're using
reporting services on top of this you
can build your own reports to to surely
information so by using workflow to deal
with our optimization problem here and
where we have this ability to separate
out the person who writes the workflow
the person who lays out all the little
activities on the work fluences this is
the order they should be executed we
separate that from the person who uses
the workflow the advantages of this is
for example you might have a business
process which says okay these are the
order things need to be executed so a
senior engineer can design the workflow
but a fairly new engineer can take the
workflow and actually execute it but it
offers you some guarantees about the the
results that this new engineer is
getting from the data so you get the
separation here you also applies you
with some sort of quality assurance
because you're you're guaranteed that
the workflow is orchestrating the the
activities in the correct order for you
and we've all this also demonstrates
that you can use it as an interrupt
between windows and in our case Linux
machines so the first one the
rolls-royce one is basically dealing
with how do I manage processes how do I
orchestrate my my work process my
business process the next proof of
concept is is done with airbus and we're
looking at how do I manage the metadata
that's produced from this how do I
manage the data and metadata so for this
example we have a unit of data is a
business object a business object is
zero or more files a business object has
metadata associated with it and a
business object can be related to one or
zero or more other business objects that
is the entire data structure so for
example if you had an aeroplane the
model and a model has many measures and
I mesh as many flow solutions now the
complexity comes here because
I would probably want to do a query that
says I would like you to return all flow
solutions where the mesh has a cell
count greater than 12 million and the
model has a mac number greater than one
so there's a need to manage not just the
metadata and query across the metadata
but there's also a need to manage and
query across the relationships of the
metadata and this is fairly difficult
for this we're using SharePoint Server
sharepoint enables you to store and
managed metadata it provides search for
other facilities built in and so we're
not changing anything in here we're just
using the inbuilt features and we're
using WCF which is windows communication
foundation web services to to expose the
data I'll show you a diagram so when I
mentioned SharePoint people often think
okay web pages we're actually not even
exposing the SharePoint front end to the
end-user at all sharepoint actually has
WCF services underneath which you can
which you can hook into and you can use
for your own applications we've extended
the service we've just added our own
service because we would like to be able
to search across the relationships of
data so we've added this service the
reason for that is if you look on the
left or the right there's flight pad
this is the client application the
client application is written in python
is cross-platform and so WCF services
are actually leave the use of us star
standards so we can talk to it through
Python the file server underneath is
actually set kept separate the file
server is where we're storing the data
as opposed to SharePoint we're restoring
the metadata the reason for this well
the file server is an HP ux machine but
when you're dealing with large volumes
of data you should move to a brush
rather than a pool scenario so the
client puts a request in for some data
and the file server will share will
share up the data when it's ready this
helps you do load balancing on your file
server and as for the SharePoint
instances because we want to show that
this can scale so this has the scale to
the enterprise level and we're using
SharePoint in two stacks you get a
SharePoint farm the farm each one so
that's each of the big squares and each
is broken up into separate machines and
they do so for example the front end the
services and the database and the
indexes are run on separate machines
this helps with scalability because you
have to share points instances and you
can cross-index then so in this example
we only have two but you can cross-index
more in more sharepoint instances this
means that the metadata stored in this
case in france can be searched and
access from the UK this is a
load-balanced this is a load balance
transfer of information so the indexing
can run across fairly poor connections
ie across across this general internet
usage and and so it and so we show that
it scales so some of the key features
here are that we're using elder while
we're actually using Active Directory
but you can use ldap to pull in the user
credentials so if you think about this
now we have all this data and metadata
managed in the SharePoint and you need
to be able to do the searches with the
user context of the user coming in so
you would never you would never then
reallocate new users to your SharePoint
instance it's common the most companies
are how to run an LDAP or an ad so you
can pull in the user credentials from ad
and these user credentials can then be
used in SharePoint you can tag up the
SharePoint with extra information if you
needed like maybe some departments or
whatever they're working in that can
also appear in ad and these user
credentials are then used for the search
so when I'm searching for information
I'm only going to retrieve the
information that's that I have
permissions to access and this is very
this is very important because bearing
in mind you're using this to share and
manage your metadata for effectively all
of the data in your in your enterprise
and of course we show that its robust
reliable and scalable by running across
multiple sites so it doesn't matter if
one site goes down or not so that's kind
of looking at how do you manage your
metadata the first one was looking at
how do you how do you generate the data
the third proof of concept here is
basically looking at how do I capture
and retain knowledge
now this is quite a difficult issue so
it's not just enough to say oh I ran
this workflow with these parameters you
need to have an audit trail you need to
record this thought process that goes
behind generating your data so for
example and you may need to know why
does somebody choose x 49 for this
workflow if something goes wrong you
need to be able to go back and prove
okay at the at the moment in time that
was the best to our best of our
knowledge that was the correct parameter
and the correct value to set it to and
this is this is a slightly difficult
proof of concept so we we generated a
custom client so you've gotta have an
entry point into the system somehow so
the custom client effectively allocates
tasks to users and the scenario we have
is a new user starting with the company
and so somebody new is given for example
to wing tips for and they say your task
is to work out which wing tip is going
to be optimal in this scenario now if
you're new with the company you're
probably going to start okay and maybe I
should have already some documents maybe
I want to chat to somebody so the we
actually had the ability we're using OCS
which is office communications server as
messenger effectively and so a user can
query could basically query this client
this is our entry point and say that I'm
doing wingtip okay and that's going to
return you something along the lines of
all the files are related to that all
the chats and all the workflows that it
also returns you people so pulling back
the credentials from Active Directory
you gain an insight into maybe what
department are in what their skill set
are and so maybe it will pop up that oak
fred has the skill set wingtips so you
can start a conversation a messenger
conversation or CS in our case and you
can starts conversations here forever
I've just started what what help can you
give me so the tips might be along the
lines of or read this document and you
know be careful of this particular case
and thank you very much sort of thing
now the custom client that we have
records these conversations
and and it's up to the user to decide if
they're worth contributing towards the
task so the idea is that you're building
up a timeline of your task at the
beginning you're given the task and at
the end you're going to say this is the
correct wingtip to use but in between
there's a thought process that goes on
and there's this timeline so in this
case there will be a conversation I've
had with Fred and maybe I've been
recommended to go read some documents
and growing reason documents is it ok
these were relevant you can drag and
drop the documents into this into this
timeline as well you can have the chance
and then of course you're probably going
to end up doing some sort of analysis or
might be running a workflow and then you
can tag up the workflows as well now the
thing about this is is almost and it's a
like a feedback loop so it's a knowledge
base that's building up so the second
user that then comes in has this problem
can do this query and they will probably
be returned the same chat conversation
that I or the users hardware thread and
the reason for this is that often in
industry the same questions come up
again and they're not there's not a
formal process to manage these questions
they probably happen down in the you
know the staff canteen but you know
somebody said oh I know I know you
you're working on this you know what
what's the problem and something the
expert in the area is very often going
to end up with the same question being
asked multiple times and you can have a
formal process it says right if you've
been asked this same question twice you
must write a formal document on it and
publish this formal document people
don't really like that but this way just
by having this chat with the new user
this date this information is
automatically logged and because it's
logged and searchable it means that you
can use it for for other users that's
what we're aiming at and the technology
that's used underneath we're using
full-text search so this is built into
sequel server and this gives you the
ability to search text in any column
we're using sequel server 2008 which has
the ability to write files it's called
file streaming right files to the to the
file system as opposed to storing them
in sequel this means that the maximum
file size that you have is actually
limited by your file system and not by
sequel server this is a very handy
feature but it also means that as in our
case the user is dragging and dropping
these documents
I just I'm just streaming them through
sequel writing them to the hard drive
I'm not changing any of the file but I'm
still having the search capabilities
across these files and the technology
were using for this as I filters I
filters are you get about 40 of them
built in there actually what's used when
you when you take the box on search on
when you're in explorer and usually
search the contents of a file it's
actually using an i filter there to pull
out the text that's all it does is it
pulls out the text contents of a file
and you can use these I filters you can
write your own I filter you can put them
in sequel server and sequel server then
we'll automatically index these files
for you so that's a couple of
technologies that were using their that
we're fairly new and so basically what
what we're trying to get forward here is
that there are over three levels so the
first level was to be a proof of concept
this is looking at okay I need to
generate data I need to be or to
orchestrate my processes now I've kept a
suitably abstract from the actual
underlying implementation because these
are problems that are occurring across
wide ranges of applications so you have
a little processes a lot of applications
that you need to execute you need to
manage and orchestrate these
applications you need to provide some
sort of tracking an audit trail on these
applications to prove what data went
into them what data came out of them and
you need to apply some processing power
to it so we're using HPC
high-performance computer server so
that's the technology underneath that
we're using for that and that's the aim
for that and then above that you have
that ok once I've generated my data what
do I do with my data on a large scale
we're talking tens tens hundreds of
millions of business objects in this
example how can I get this to scale how
can I get it to scale globally what
technology can I use now you can go out
and use you could write your own
technology to do this but the idea is
that we're looking at taking standard
technology that we know that scales to
the enterprise taking this technology
and applying it to the engineering
problems so once you have your metadata
you have your metadata it's managed it
stores you need to be able to prove that
there's some sort of security on this
data you need to be able to prove that
people are not going to be able to
access data they shouldn't be allowed to
X
so that that's what we're using the
SharePoint for and then finally there's
this there's this top layer of like okay
what how do you apply how do you store
this audit trail and this this comes in
from if you've got a high turnover of
staff how do you record this knowledge
people come people go some industries
that's not a problem but if you look at
the error industry they have to record
this information for 50 60 70 years plus
and if there's a problem they need to go
back and look at these files and they
need to be able to prove that they made
the best decision at that time based on
the best information they had at that
time so you need to be able to provide
this thought process here and the idea
is that we're using fairly nourished
technologies so actually one thing that
was also used in the BAE when we're
using hyper V so this is looking at
virtualizing everything so the reason we
did this there's multiple reasons for
doing it the reason we did this really
is to show off the features of hyper-v
but they're the most of the industries
are now heading along to virtualized
servers you can go by yourself
virtualize however if you look at
Windows Azure which is coming out now
these are all VMS are running and even
if you're not interested so much in just
the vm you also have the ability to
these virtual hard drives and there's
it's almost out now the ability to boot
your hardware natively from a virtual
hard drive this means that you can
switch in and switch out operating
systems by just switching a file on so
we're using hyper-v just to show the
features of it and it does mean that of
course i can move out of eight machines
i put them all on one and i can still
run the demo if i if i go anywhere and
the key thing about this is really that
you're pulling away this infrastructure
issues from the engineers the engineer
should not be worrying about all these
computer science problems the engineer
should be sitting here and be able to
get on with the actual engineering
problem that they're employed to do and
I think there are a couple of minutes if
there are any questions before if
they're my email is actually on the
first and last slide I'm really keen to
hear any questions people have if they
don't get time to ask any today and bear
with us a second I'll hand microphones
for questions for recording purposes so
please wait for the microphone
okay it's about that what kind of
metadata are you are you using are you
using for example ontology Oriental
languages or what good kind of languages
are using okay so for the metadata this
is this is legacy data there isn't
really an ontology or a form grammar but
its metadata that's used in the arrow
industry so we're not actually adopting
an ontology for this because they
already have a very clear understanding
clear as it gets understanding of what
metadata they are using plus there's a
lot of ongoing work into formalizing
these these are formalizing the grammar
for this and formalizing the metadata so
what we're actually looking at here is
the metadata comes in we're not worried
so much about you know x equals 5 we're
not so worried about what's the grammar
for x what does it actually mean we're
adding the capability for you can say
okay I would like to search for all of X
greater than 5 less than 5 equal to and
there the series of all creatures that
you can use their the actual formal
ontology of this is something that it's
actually quite a big job in a few if you
look at it two or three week project
you're never going to be able to tackle
that but there are people that are
working on this already you know I was
just wondering because you were speaking
a lot about windows workflow foundation
I was wondering if you guys rehosted the
workflow designer or what kind of dudes
you guys might have for designing these
workflows right so the the designer is
actually completely Rijo stable it's
just a dotnet object we rehost it in our
own custom application just a windows
form and there's also an ongoing project
not separate from this that is using
that's rehosted on a web page so which a
question also related to the the actual
hosting of the runtime or just the
hosting of the the visualizer just the
hosting of the designer which I believe
you know just allows the client to
design the workflow right because
there's one other thing that comes out
of this and my big bug bear with
workflow basically is there's no there's
no hosting environment you get the wrong
time but you don't get hosting
environment
and they're bringing out the new version
hopefully very very soon and it's called
it's called name dublin at the moment
but it gives you the hosting runtime so
you don't actually have to worry about
hosting the runtime yourself it's
already provided so it's just occasion
installing it and it appears in iis
which simplifies things greatly and this
will be the final question I hope it's
worth it so I didn't understand
everything you're presenting but I think
you're saying that a lot if not all of
the Airbus's of Airbus's work involves
workflows is that true is everything
they do end up being in a workflow in
some way or is the system have to also
capture other work I know so the be a
one looked at and running was running
the workflow the air boss one that we
were looking at was managing the
metadata they don't internally to the
best of my knowledge they have their own
workflow does those bae run everything
with work phone no not yet but this is
what the proof-of-concept looking at is
to see how can your workflow scale
because bear in mind that these
workflows when they're not when they're
not being used they get taken out of
memory so you can scale this to hundreds
of thousands of workflows running at the
same time and the workflow will
rehydrate will
and well I mean I guess there's always
going to be a case where you wouldn't
use workflow and the the main reason
that they're looking at the workflow is
to provide this tracking so that would
be where the issue comes is can you
provide enough tracking for in this case
bae so will they be able to extend the
tracking and the answer to that is yes
you can extend the tracking that would
be the area they look at bear in mind
that its workflow is very it's generic I
think it came from it's made for
managing workflow in offices and banking
so and we're applying it to engineering
but it's a generic workflow you can
extend your own activities you can
extend the tracking you can extend it
almost as much as you like Catherine
Blake is our next